so we have the formula for an ionic
compound here and the goal of this video
is what do we call this thing it clearly
involves some cobalt and some sulfur but
how would we name it
well the convention is is the first
element to be listed is going to be our
cation and if we look at cobalt over
here we see that it is a d-block element
and d-block elements are tricky because
you don't know exactly how it will
ionize so we know that this is going to
be our cation it's going to be our
positive ion but we don't know what the
charge on each of those cobalt is
actually going to be
so now let's look at the anion let's
look at the sulfur
or as an anion the sulfide
so let me underline
that
and on the periodic table we see sulfur
is out here that it would that in its
group it would want to gain two
electrons in order to have a complete
outer shell it's just like oxygen it
wants to gain two electrons so the
sulfide anion will look like this
so it will have
sulfur when it ionizes will have a 2
minus charge just like oxygen just like
everything else in this group it would
want to gain 1 2 electrons so that its
outer shell looks like that of a
noble gas looks like that of argon
so we can use this as a clue to figure
out what must be the charge on the
cobalts because we have three of the
sulfides
we have
each of the sulfides has a
two minus charge and we have three of
them so that's going to give us a six
minus charge all in
and then the cobalt
the cobalt
we have
two of them
and so these two cobalts have to offset
these this six minus charge they have to
have a six plus charge well that means
that each of them need to have a three
plus charge if each of these have a
three plus charge and you have two of
them then you're going to have six plus
on the positive side and you're gonna
have six minus from the sulfides and the
reason why this is useful for us is now
we can name this
we would call this we would call this
ionic compound
cobalt
three
cobalt and you would write with roman
numerals here cobalt 3 sulfide
cobalt 3
sulfide now i know what you might be
thinking hey when we looked at other
ionic compounds i didn't have to write
the charge of the cation there and the
reason why the convention is to do it
here and actually let me i don't have to
i don't have to
write it an uppercase there so let me
rewrite it as cobalt
cobalt
three
sulfide
the reason why i wrote that three in
this case is because the cobalt can take
on multiple charges it's known as
polyvalent
polyvalent if something is in group one
you know it tends to have a positive one
charge group two tends to have positive
two charge if it's a halide tends to
have negative one charge but these
metals here in this d block here they
could have they could be ionized in
multiple ways and so that's why we had
to figure out what the charge of the
cobalt is and we write it here in the
name we would call this cobalt three
sulfide you could have other other
ionizations of cobalt and other ionic
compounds but this one is cobalt three
sulfide and you could go either way you
could say okay if the cobalt
has a charge of three plus you could
figure out its formula right over here
or as we just did in this video you
could go from the formula to the actual
dave